repaso y actualización de las noticias
económicas con luis méndez zúrich e
buenas noches de nuevo luis para ustedes
y vamos a volver a eeuu con las
declaraciones del senador joe manchin
que complican a joe biden con su plan de
gasto que es ángela pero en líneas
generales el demócrata pidió a la cámara
de representantes- votar por el plan de
infraestructura estimado en un billón de
dólares que ya cuenta con la aprobación
del senado
a juicio de hahn sin lograr un acuerdo
sobre el plan propuesto de 15 75
millones de dólares cuya inversión está
orientada al gasto social y a la
mitigación del impacto del cambio
climático podría tomar más tiempo con
jim en sus declaraciones calificó como
reina el plan de infraestructura y
responsabilizó a los demócratas de la
cámara de retenerlo hasta asegurar su
respaldo al plan de 175 millones de
dólares pero escuchemos que dijo manchin
durante su encuentro con los medios he
dicho simplemente no apoyaré una ley tan
consecuente como ésta sin haber
entendido en profundidad el impacto que
tendrá en nuestra deuda nacional nuestra
economía y lo más importante para el
pueblo estadounidense ninguno de
nosotros debería jamás tergiversar al
pueblo estadounidense cuál es el
verdadero costo de una legislación
aunque yo he trabajado duro para
encontrar un camino hacia el acuerdo
mutuo es obvio que eso no es lo
suficientemente bueno para muchos de mis
colegas en el congreso es todo o nada y
su posición no parece cambiar a no ser
que nosotros estemos de acuerdo en todo
ya es suficiente pero veamos que
contiene cada plan como hemos indicado
la ley de infraestructura comprende una
inversión de 1 billón de dólares y se
orienta a gastos federales para la
expansión de internet reparación y
nuevas obras de infraestructura
fondos para el servicio ferroviario el
plan de gasto también llamado ley de
política social prevé invertir en 10
años 1.75 billones de dólares inversión
que iría destinada a la infancia la
puesta en marcha de un plan para mitigar
el impacto del cambio climático y
también para el refuerzo en la atención
médica uno de los temas que han sido
recurrente en nuestros noticieros de hoy
es el de argentina que abrió totalmente
sus fronteras para el turismo ángela una
medida que fue aplaudida por los
operadores turísticos de la nación y que
busca con solo a este sector como una de
las principales fuentes de recursos para
el país vale decir que desde el cierre
de sus fronteras en marzo de 2020
argentina dejó de percibir alrededor de
3 mil millones de dólares producto de
las actividades turísticas de acuerdo
con la agencia de noticias efe que cita
fuentes oficiales los ingresos por
turismo en 2020 se ubicaron por el orden
de los mil 616 millones de dólares es
decir un 69,2 por ciento si se compara
con los cinco mil 241 millones que
ingresaron en el año 2019 pero
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo el
presidente de la federación de cámaras
de turismo
de este turismo a partir de noviembre
significa una entrada extra y muy
importante que lo va a significar no
solamente tener más ingresos sino que
cubrir la parte de los pasivos por estas
pandemias que hemos tenido y por
supuesto pasando un tiempo realmente
importante empezar a tener los
excedentes para poder invertir en esta
actividad que hemos tenido un año y
medio cerrado más de américa latina
mejoró la previsión de crecimiento para
costa rica así lo voy a conocer el banco
central de ese país este lunes al
modificar la previsión de crecimiento a
5.4 por ciento desde el 3 9 por ciento
va a conocer el informe presentado en
julio pasado de acuerdo con el
presidente de la institución rodrigo
cool pero la producción del país alcanzó
durante el tercer trimestre de 2021 los
niveles previos a la pandemia asimismo
el organismo elevó la previsión de
crecimiento del país para el próximo año
al ubicarla en 4,5 por ciento desde el
37 % del mes de julio y la aerolínea
ryanair dio a conocer sus resultados
trimestrales y estos fueron los primeros
en los que la aerolínea costo reporta
ganancias desde el año 2019 los ingresos
netos fueron según sus directivos de 225
millones de euros una cifra lejos de la
esperada por los analistas de 255
millones de euros ahora la empresa no
descarta mantener los precios bajos de
boleto para continuar así la senda de
recuperación cuáles son los indicadores
de la jornada en wall street hubo
números positivos a lo largo de las
jornadas sobre todo por las ganancias
que presentaron en algunas empresas en
europa también se dieron números
positivos y sobre todo por la
espectativa que hay en torno a la
reunión de la reserva federal del
próximo miércoles en japón los números
también fueron positivos y en américa
latina hubo cierres mixtos a lo largo de
la jornada destacando el caso de
argentina donde a pesar del riesgo país
subió potencialmente su mercado y su
cifra tiene que ver con los 6 mil
millones de dólares que estaría
ofreciendo el dueño de tesla y los modos
para combatir la hambruna en todo el
pues muchísimas gracias a usted lo dice
a nuestros televidentes continúen ya
volvemos con más noticias
[Música]